I'm not Nick lemon actually hello my
name is Gil Agha I'm a Columbia alumnus
i'm also the anchor and executive
producer of capital a prime-time
business and investigative show on m6
french TV as a member of the host
committee and as journalists i'd like to
tell you how proud I am to introduce
this media panel Columbia changed my
life it's been almost 20 years since I
graduated from general studies and then
journalism but my education at Columbia
still inspires me today the reason is
quite simple beyond learning the
techniques of reporting in writing the
school of journalism taught me something
that I believed to be fundamental to
become a journalist the purpose of
journalism is not just to deliver news
reporting the news means explaining and
deciphering information in other words
putting facts in perspective so that the
people that you work for that is the
public the citizens have a better
knowledge about what's going on around
them which ultimately leads them to make
better choices in their lives this was I
believe Joseph blizzards philosophy when
he created the school in the 1900s in
the early 1900s here's what he said at
the time our republic will rise or fall
together a cynical mercenary the magic
press were producing time a people as
bases itself the power to mold the
future of the Republic will be in the
hands of the journalists a future
generation well the statement stayed
with me since I left school basically
what it means is that journalism is a
public service and therefore an
essential tool for democracy I believe I
would not be holding the job I have
today had it not been for my education
at Columbia this is why I'm involved
today
with CAA to have the opportunity to
speak out about these principles and i
believe it is even more critical and
crucial today with the intense
development of new media when i
graduated in nineteen ninety you only
have three types of media basically
print radio television at the time you
had CNN but fox news did not exist MSNBC
did not exist al Jazeera of course did
not exist the internet had not yet
invaded our lives nor had this small
object mobile phone so how's the surge
of these new media changing the way we
journalists do our job especially with
the advance of blogs and citizen
reporters another question is in an era
dominated by political spin doctors and
communication driven corporation how can
these media help us remain independent
in the way report news and overall in a
global globalized world can journalists
transcend national perspective to
address these issues let me introduce
you to four outstanding figures in
journalism he pegged gem taha host and
producer of global programs on NTV
turkey michael or s Keys executive
editors of the Hale Tribune Richardson
Brook director of bbc's global news &
our moderator Nick lemon the Dean of the
Columbia University Graduate School of
Journalism Nick lemon